[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
the charge seems to be
being too loud
WOW black
scenes in Tennessee they're not hiding
it
we know who you are and we see who you
are listen fascists out there
better just get use
to loud
I think that's gonna be
over the next 18 months two years is
just going to be the theme
if you're gonna say and do
bigoted things
because of your bigoted beliefs and use
the government and our democracy
to Institute your fascism into our
society
pair for us to be loud yesterday
I watched
two black members of the of the
Tennessee legislator
Justin Jones and Justin Pearson
very smart articulate well thought out
young men
I watched the Tennessee Republican
caucus the racist Tennessee
Republican caucus the America First
Nazis
in Tennessee
we all the world watched
as they expelled those members for being
black
some say
this is a crack in our institution some
say it is a crack in our democracy
I believe
that is the curtain that is being pulled
back
from the thin veiled word of
conservatism
for their racism their bigotry and more
importantly their fascism to be shown
behind that curtain
yesterday Gloria Johnson
a white woman was also
voted on to be expelled and she was not
by one vote
way to let your racism show their
Republicans
the Republicans in Tennessee
created what almost seems like out of
thin air
two International
civil rights activist
now these two young men have a lot of
history
in activism and civil rights in
Tennessee in Nashville
but yesterday
the world learned who they were
and a few Republicans got up and spoke
and asked really stupid
questions obviously they gave away why
in those questions why they were
expelling the two black men and not the
white woman
but they even suspended the rules
they knew they didn't have a case
you don't expel members from a
legislative body because they're too
loud or they're loud when they shouldn't
be loud
folks I say this all the time while the
fascist
are holding the shovel to their
political grave
and they're digging the hole do not
take the shovel out of their hands
matter of fact give them a backhoe and I
believe that is what the Republicans in
Tennessee yesterday did
they got out the back over their
political Graves
this is not the end
of Representative Pearson this is not
the end of Representative Jones
they only Amplified their microphone
and the world is responding
do you think anyone around this country
that bears an R after their name
are gonna stick their neck out
to defend what the Republicans in
Tennessee did yesterday and if they do
we should get out the acts of democracy
folks
it's time
now
is the time to be loud
I don't care where I don't care when it
is time to get loud because there's one
thing a fascist
are obviously terrified of
and it is your voice
it is the collective of the
pro-democracy coalition
the voices of the people
for the change that we know we want
in Tennessee this started with three
dead children and three dead teachers
in a school a Christian school in
Nashville
these Representatives these Tennessee
three they didn't go to the well during
the recess to get loud
because they were trying to protect
protect
some some unknown thing
they're trying to make sure that
children are safe in schools
it seems like something to get loud
about
it feels like to me that this country
stands behind the idea of making sure
children are not ripped apart by weapons
of war inside their little Elementary
classrooms
this is what Republicans in Tennessee
were scared of
what baffles me
is that the Republicans every single
time
totally underestimate
the popularity of their ideology
totally underestimated
with Reckless abandon
they only proved yesterday that they are
willing to go to any extent and any
excuse necessary even suspend the rules
of their body
to expel members of that body because
those members were loud when they didn't
want them to be
and yesterday when they voted to expel
the two young black men from that
legislator and not the the white lady
you only gave away more of your game
We Know Who You Are
so please
please come out behind the bail of
conservatism you're not conservatives
Jesus Christ the KKK was founded in
Tennessee and by God in the Republican
legislator it lives today
I'm gonna show you a clip
it's brilliant
of Representative Pearson
absolutely brilliant
what this young man says and how he
defends democracy
don't they know that the gun reform
they're asking for
is democracy don't you know that you
[__] Nazis
they don't
because they're not conservative folks
they're not
I watched a clip of Scott Walker the
former you probably don't know who that
is
because he's a nobody just like Ron
DeSantis soon will be a nobody he's the
former governor of Wisconsin
As We Know
the voices of the pro-democracy
Coalition in Wisconsin were heard this
week
and they said not just no but hell no to
fascism by 11 [__] points
and Scott Walker the former the former
Republican
front runner for the presidency do you
remember that until we went to I Iowa
and then lost big time floundered
because they're not as good as they
think they are
says that he sees a problem with so many
young people voting
it's a real problem these educated young
people when they go to college
they're indoctrinated by liberalism
he would love to say the word woke but
he knows that the word woke is worn out
well guess what
pen the badge of liberalism on you folks
and be proud of it
liberalism
is the founding strength
of our democracy
conservatism
is the founding weakness of our
democracy
say it loud and say it proud
there's no reason to hide from being a
liberal
hell most people don't even know they
are
never looked up to word
never gandered at it on the Google
not once
but yesterday
yesterday when fascism in Tennessee was
thin veiled as conservatism
we saw exactly
what they're trying to use conservatism
and liberalism to be
it's as plain as black and white
no justice no peace comes to mind
as Justin Jones
gave an eloquent speech
and eloquent answers
to the dumbest questions I have ever
heard a republican legislator form
towards another member who was loud
when they didn't want him to be
I wonder what the um
Tennessee legislators the racist
Republicans in Tennessee
who voted to expel the two black young
black members but not the white woman I
wonder I wonder what their feelings are
when you ask them about cancel culture I
wonder what they would say when you ask
him about their freedom of speech
can you only imagine what these [__]
idiots would say of course you don't
have to imagine you would know exactly
what they would say
the projection of entitlement of their
whiteness on the floor of the chamber
in which
three members were loud when they didn't
want them to be
and they're entitled to do whatever
whenever they want they don't they
didn't even refer these charges
of expulsion to the Ethics Committee oh
that would take way too long and that
would be too much of a process
they wanted to get rid of the black
legislators as fast and quick as
possible because those two black men not
only are they black
but they were loud and they were
effective at being loud
and they are shining too much of a light
on what the the vile nature of the
Republican caucus in Tennessee really
truly is
they're gonna ban books
they're gonna ban drag they're gonna try
to legislate trans people out of
existence
and they want to remove all black
members of their legislator
who get out of line and don't conform to
what they see as whiteness on the floor
of their chamber
we see you you [__] Nazis we [__]
see you
this is not the end
of Representative Jones
this is not the end of Justin
represented Justin Pearson folks
this is only
the beginning
of their voices being loud
even though the Republicans didn't
afford the two black men
the right to go before the Ethics
Committee to explain why they were a
little too loud at the moment that white
people didn't want them to be
seems to be a trend huh
now there's going to be Council meetings
to vote them back in
my guess is one false move by Justin
Pearson or Justin Jones if they are
afforded their seat back to the
legislator by the city councils
my guess is they'll challenge it
and they should
you should this is a test of democracy
folks
this is the test
they're trying to see how far they can
actually go
they're trying to figure out how much
power they truly have inside our
government
and the fascists are putting us to the
test
so are you going to fail that test
now are you going to give up because I I
know clearly representative Pearson
representative Jones are not going to
give up representative Johnson is not
going to give her fight up even though
she wasn't expelled she's definitely not
going to give her fight up for the two
Representatives that were because they
were black
so are you
again I tell you all the time you are
the best audience in the world
and you listen to this microphone every
single weekday for two hours sometimes
three
from front to back last month even with
a seven minute or seven day suspension
on YouTube we had five almost five
million minutes viewed
on this small little show
just on YouTube
but use your microphone
use your I'm only one microphone you are
thousands of microphones
use it
now is the time to engage in our
democracy
they are testing us now more than ever
2024 is not going to be an easy fight
and I'm not just talking about the
presidential race I'm talking about
races in the Senate and these State
houses in the city councils in the
school boards the governor's races the
Attorney General races the Secretary of
State races
it comes down to you
and when we stand with one voice
and say no justice no peace
and we live
in a country where we love democracy
we get results like we did in Wisconsin
this week
they are not the majority folks and I
know some people say Tony Tennessee is
red as red as red can be
good luck to you
as we use our microphones more and more
people will understand what liberalism
is more and more people aren't going to
understand
how the perpetuation of bigotry only
sets back their own liberty
but we must be loud
we must be proud
and we shall not back down from this
fight
I'm gonna show you some powerful Clips
today
powerful clips
of Justin Jones and Justin Pearson
and Gloria Johnson
absolutely powerful statements
brother Jones stood on the floor I
watched almost the entirety of his
20-minute speech I watched a lot of the
questions that he answered
he was quoting scripture
from the Bible
to White
Christian nationalist who their only
their only problem with brother Jones is
that he is too black and too loud and
we're looking at you speaker Sexton you
[__] snowflake
yesterday was bittersweet day in
democracy
bittersweet
because they are using it
they are using democracy to try to tear
it to the ground because it does not
serve their fascist purpose
but yesterday the world saw their
intention
we know who you are we know what you are
doing
to our country
our democracy and our Republic
we understand it
and I cannot believe
I cannot believe
that the Republican party is so far down
the Maka rabbit hole
that they did not see the backlash that
is about to come
from all over this country
the black community people of color gen
Z
they have only only solidified the
pro-democracy coalition
and to bring it to a state house
to make sure that this battle that they
thought that they wanted to win played
out on the floor of a state legislator
not the United States Congress
now people are going to go wait a second
if they're doing that in Tennessee are
they doing that [__] in Alabama
are they doing it in Florida are they
doing that sort of [__] in Missouri
what about Texas in the state legislator
it's a [__]
it's a [__] when you're against wokism
but it really is it really is a stupid
[__] move
to make the majority of the country woke
to your fascism everybody we are woke
here to their fascism we know what
they're doing we know what they're we
know what yeah well I'm on to you you
sons of [__] I'm gonna show you a lot
a lot of great footage today
some powerful statements I I I am I am
very encouraged
very encouraged that the Republicans in
Tennessee decided to make not not only
make representative Pearson
representative Jones National figures
but maybe the face of a movement
that absolutely will Pummel them
with love heart faith and soul
that's right I'm excited I'm excited
about them being that saying the quiet
part out loud doing the quiet part out
loud we will politicize this we will use
this we will get loud
and we will be allies to anyone who is
pro-democracy in this nation and we will
we will have a coalition that will crush
fascism in 2024 not just at the
presidential level level not just in the
United States Senate not just in the
United States Congress but in state
houses City councils School boards all
the way down to the God damn dog
catchers
foreign
to turn your microphone on
and turn it up
because we're gonna get loud and they're
terrified
terrified of loud noises everyone stick
around we'll be right back right after
this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard in blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show of loud noises
ah ow buddy oh
don't pick the shovel out of their hands
when they're digging their political
grave don't take it out hell Hannibal
back though
I think we should do here you go
dig a deeper hole dummy
[Music]
that is the most amazing thing to me of
the whole thing I I just cannot believe
that they were like you know what's a
good idea do you know what's a good idea
we'll do any excuse to get rid of those
two black dudes that we don't like
even even disguise it with with a white
woman that came up and was loud with him
now let me let me give you a little idea
about legislators and expelling members
okay
we have a legislative body in this
country that in 2020 there were several
members
of that body that is alleged that they
were trying to overturn our vote
of that legislative body now every
single one of them are white
none of them have been charged with a
crime yet
it feels like some of them are close to
being
there's a lot of them there's one in
particular that is in a heated battle in
court to make sure that his cell phone
records are not seized so they aren't on
to him for the coup attempt
not one of them has been charged with a
crime or even even the hint of expulsion
from that body and they tried to
overturn your vote using their power in
that legislative body now let me put it
in perspective here for you a bit
when representative Jones Pearson and
Johnson went to the well
to be loud
the Speaker of the House Sexton
that [__] scumbag gavel to recess
when you recess there is no official
business on the floor
it's just a room at that point
that they were loud in
that's it that's it
and yesterday if you watched what
happened let me describe to you
how expulsion would probably normally
work in almost any legislative body that
we have in this country now each state
is a little different
their Constitutions are different they
have different rules for their
legislators some of them meet every two
years every year every it just depends
on that State's Constitution
a lot of them are very similar to the
United States Constitution in some ways
especially the way that those
legislators
have order and Rule
and yesterday yesterday
the Republicans voted to suspend the
rules
they suspended their own rules
of that body
and the reason why is because they
needed an excuse to bring a motion of
expulsion
normally a motion of expulsion would
come from a committee
to the floor like I don't know ethics
the reason why Republicans did not want
to have an Ethics Committee bring these
charges to the floor is because
there would have been no charges
it would have been ridiculous
for republicans
to vote for expulsion in an Ethics
Committee voices would be heard debate
would be had it would be very difficult
and a very long process and a very
public process to bring this to the
floor
that's not what Republicans wanted
what Republicans wanted and did was
suspend their own rules
on the floor voted to suspend
they didn't just gavel it out folks when
you vote when you suspend the rules
you have to vote to suspend the rules
and there has to be 66 votes in the
Tennessee legislator
oh there was way more than 66 votes
people in Tennessee are deluded they
don't know that they're liberal and they
vote based on abortion and drag shows
there in Tennessee
and they love the institution of white
supremacy they think it protects their
privilege they don't want equity and
equality
because they think it is it is
oppression to their privilege
and when you are the oppressor you want
to oppress
so they vote in people who are not of
their own interest
that is the uphill battle we have
but in Tennessee there was enough votes
on the floor to suspend their own rules
to play a video that was about seven
minutes long now it started the video
started with a with a video we watched
the other day I believe I believe I
played that video it was from Tennessee
holler it had their moniker on it
it was from the gallery there at the
Capitol
and they were filming down into the well
when Jones Pearson and Johnson began to
speak
with a bullhorn
and the video ended with two other clips
from two other members on the floor
now in the Republicans rules
it is against the rules to have a camera
and record from
the floor
it's against the rules
now Republicans argument was well wait a
second those cameras were turned on and
recorded these three Representatives
being loud
being loud I'm not kidding you
it recorded these representatives for
being loud
after the speaker
had gaveled for recess
so
what that means is they weren't breaking
the rules because it was recess
in peer debate style fashion Democrats
seized on this opportunity
to call a point of order and say whoa
whoa wait a second are you telling me
that you can't break the rules because
there are no rules after it's called The
Recess so why are we challenging these
three members on being too loud against
the rules
they were not recognized
to speak on the floor but if there was
recess and the rules did not apply then
why do the rules apply to these three
members and the reason why is because
two of them were black
that was the answer I mean they didn't
want to say that I mean come on
they want you know us to connect the
dots from A to B at least a little bit
this isn't
1963. in America in Tennessee
or is it
after they played their video and after
the heated debate
the Republicans gave the Democrats an
opportunity to speak
from the well
the only time the Republicans there give
opportunity for them to speak
and they spoke
and they took questions
which I think the Republicans thought oh
we'll show we'll show these uppity boys
and we'll question them real good
well question after question only
revealed their real intent
Justin Jones Justin Pearson or activist
Justin Jones before he was state
representative worked hard to remove a
bust
of a KK klansman
from the state capitol and won that
battle
and it seems
that the white men in the legislator
there are still a little upset
at representative Jones
for winning that fight
on removing that bust
the facts folks
they don't like Jones they don't like
Pearson because they do not assimilate
into their style and fashion of what a
black legislator is allowed to be in
Tennessee
representative Jones and Pearson
are having [__] none of it
and I'm proud to see it
and to be quite honest with you
yesterday
as I watched them expel those two
members from the Tennessee house
my heart warmed not broke
my heart is not broken
my heart warmed
when representative Jones and Pearson
went out into the Hall outside the
chamber
and those people cheered for them
cheered them to fight on
chanted for them to fight on
and this is only the beginning of their
fight
these two men are young
these two men are gonna be National
civil rights activists for the rest of
their days
yesterday we didn't know at the
beginning of the day
how eloquent and how intelligent
and how passionate
brother Jones
and Justin Pearson are today
not only our country but the entire
world knows the entire world knows
and that is what warms my heart
oh baby it warms my heart Gabe Sanchez
and the reason why it really does warm
my heart is because
of the antifa newsletter that went out a
week ago it said hey if we're going to
get rid of Republicans in this country
and and fix them good here's what we do
we just let them
throw themselves is step one stand back
and let them destroy themselves by
voting to expel to
black men from the legislators because
they don't like how black and how loud
they are
and step step two
step two to destroy the Republican party
is milkshakes that's what I think I mean
stand stand back and stand by right and
drink your milkshake I mean drink your
milkshake I love a good milkshake but
yeah it's one of those things where you
just watch it happen and unfold
because the language that was used to
describe the actions they took last week
was this was an Insurrection right this
was just like January 6th right and then
you've got you know that's Cameron
Sexton right and you've got Cameron
Sexton also the one who actually
physically had an altered like a
physical altercation with brother Jones
right like he took his phone and pushed
him and like that was lappardy that was
laughing yeah yeah okay yeah just to be
clear yeah I want to be factual right so
uh
and you look at that party the party
that's like oh you know what we're gonna
vote these two uppity black men out of
this house because God forbid we stand
up for you know the innocent people who
have died and want to prevent future
innocent people and children from dying
right however the thing there is that
the Republican party doesn't care right
they don't they don't somebody says I
have Bed Head this is this is this is me
out of the shower and I walked outside
this is that shower here this is shower
hair baby so so I I think you make an
interesting point there but I actually
think it's a lot more simple
than than the complication of gun reform
and and that sort of thing right the
reason why is because Republicans don't
give a [__]
they could care less they like that NRA
money right they like that [__] and they
like the fear of guns I mean NRA money
is like [__] catnip yeah Republicans
they're more blood on that money the
better so yeah here's what I think this
is
um because I've got a video here I think
somewhere here of um brother Jones
representative Jones before he was
representative Jones where he was at the
Capitol
protesting to take a bust of a KKK
member out of the capital and he won
that fight eventually he was one of the
activists that fought hard for that
I actually believe that the white
Christian nationalists inside the Texas
Republican caucus there and the
legislator I believe they don't like
Jones or Pearson no for a lot of
different reasons I mean there's uh
everyone
but they see him as a threat but I
believe that the opportunity that they
used here wasn't wasn't about gun reform
or wasn't about them being loud it's
that these two black members these two
young black men who were members of
their legislative body were very
effective very I mean look how many
thousands of people showed up at the
state capitol right to say in one voice
do something [__] something to
save children do something red flag back
anything anything but what you're doing
which is the opposite
they saw them as power
that they saw them as power
well they also that's what they're
scared of yeah well it's also the fact
that those those you know older white
men you know they realistically someone
say this did I say Texas I'm in
Tennessee Tennessee Texas I mean come on
what are you gonna do well you look at
Tennessee and you see these people you
see these older white men and some of
them weren't white dude I saw some I
there was one guy his nickname is Doc
and I forget his full name but his
nickname is Doc and he was like oh I'm
I'm a person of color I'm not white and
I've never heard a racial slur slurred
like derogatory term used I was like
[__] no you have yes you have you
definitely have people have said that
[__] behind your back people have always
said that [__] because that's how this
country is it's racist it's terrible
it's awful but we can do better but the
fact that you're with the Republican
party and you're unwilling to accept it
makes brother Jones writes right when he
says that you're putting Brown on white
supremacy right you're putting your
brown skin on white supremacy you are
protecting it and that's what the and
that's what the Logan party does but the
main thing I think is that they see
these two
uh
powerful voices young powerful voices in
that house they see them as a threat
not because
they speak what everyone is thinking
but they see them as a threat as a
threat because one what they're saying
is popular but I think the main thing is
they see their legacy
being sunsetted by a younger generation
who is done right we talk about gen Z we
talk about you know even young
Millennials there's we're part of a
group that is fed up right and you look
at these people in there who voted
to take them out right because that's
what it was right if you want to talk
about political persecution let's talk
about that okay because that's what that
was that was a fascist that was that was
that was textbook fascism to remove your
uh your enemy right even though they're
the they're they're working for the the
the people
remove them because they're young
they're going to be replaced and they
see younger powerful independent you
know passionate voices like you were
saying we're gonna see them they're
afraid that their legacy is going to be
uh removed and they can't have that so
they need to they need to squash it
right now as a warning to say if you
ever if you ever give up out of your
seat to do more than just vote
will expel you right and that's that's
the [__] up situation we're in don't
be loud while black that is something
that you are not going to do in this
body and that is obviously what sexton
in in the uh Tennessee Republicans tried
yesterday on these members here is one
this this clip is from MSNBC
now someone changed it right they didn't
you're gonna see what they changed and
they tweeted this they said what year is
this from I think this is brilliant
watch watch this clip here
um of Representative Pearson as he
speaks about his his eventual expulsion
to be able to have control over our
legislation regarding my mind right now
is we need to fight for democracy in the
state of Tennessee and we need people
not only just to vote but people to show
up and speak out so that we can end the
gun violence epidemic that's happening
in our state this is wrong this is
unjust and this is not the way that it
has to be there is a better way for us
to live and we don't have to live this
way but the Republican Party of the
state of Tennessee want to keep things
the same if you want to fight the
changes if you want to help them make
this place a better place you have to
use your voice you have to use your
power yes sometimes you've got a good
expense
[Music]
the injustices that are happening here
must change and I'll continue to fight
in my family will continue
[Applause]
[Music]
in District 86 I love you I thank you
and thank you for believing that
changing and fighting to change the
status quo is the right thing to do we
knew we were going to keep our
principles and our values we knew that
we were going to have our ancestors with
us we knew that we were not going to
yield to Injustice and we will not yield
because there's too much at stake we see
gun violence every single day we have
too many loved ones that we're putting
in the ground and these folks up here
treat things like it's business as usual
it is not business as usual our lives
are at stake and there you have it so
Gabe Sanchez I'll ask you the question
is it 1963 or
2023 what do you think what do you think
is from Can it can it not be both
I mean it seems like both it looks look
I mean like we chatted about this
yesterday and like
the the one the one takeaway I have is
the Republican party wants to talk about
how you know holding Trump accountable
you know for the crimes that he
committed and this is just one one
indictment right or 34 counts rather
um everyone says oh you know what you
just guaranteed the election you just
made him a martyr oh man this all that
right
but you look at what the Republican
party just did in Tennessee yep they
created
icons within within the the activist
Community right you made you made uh uh
civil rights activists and you just
propelled them into being Martyrs into
being these icons there is you cannot
look at this and say oh yeah these guys
are they're they're they're they're done
they're not they're not going to come
back ever dude if you thought dude you
[__] man if they don't come back into
the house you better believe they are
gonna [__] they're going to group and
work together for 2024 on a national
stage I can feel I honestly feel like we
have the same type of movement
from those from just those two out of
Tennessee that we would say that we
would that we saw in Georgia right like
Stacy Abrams like I'm feeling like that
type of energy and that type of power to
get people activated because again
whether or not they can come back in I
know the rules of whether they'll be
allowed back in I know I I heard some
stuff yesterday if they're expelled and
they can't actually run in a special
election well the the city councils in
their districts can actually
um
reappoint them as the legislator
um I believe in Tennessee that is where
it it now lies is in the city councils
and it's likely that they will
um the Republicans know that it's likely
and I'm actually gonna play in the
bonehead of the week
um a clip from speaker Sexton uh because
I'm Gonna Give It Away speaker six and
became the bonehead of the week
um just like that as you said these two
young intelligent inspirational faithful
black men became civil rights activists
almost at a thin air but they weren't
they've been civil rights activists
they were fighting in Tennessee for
local issues for civil rights in
Tennessee and they just created National
civil rights activists that speak for
all Americans and what's crazy to me and
we're going to get into it and bone of
the week because I know you got a heart
out yeah and I know the the audience is
going to want three hours they usually
are accustomed to that on Friday but
they're not going to get it today we got
to go to bonehead because Gabe's got to
get out of here at the top of the next
hour
um but here's the thing is that
when when you consider yesterday
when the Democrats
on the floor
while the rules were suspended because
while they were trying to vote to
suspend the rules to play this clip
the Democrats tried to give the
Republicans one last chance not to do
this thing that they were gonna do which
was going to propel these two men
to be like you said icons
in the new Civil Rights Movement
because we are in that time we are in
that place because fascists are making
it that time in that place they're
hell-bent on it there's nothing else
that matters to them I mean Jesus Christ
we watch Kid Rock shoot Bud Light cans
because they had rainbows on them yeah
which by the way I I watch it because
I'm doing a what was that on that yeah I
rewatched that clip there's gunfire
coming from off screen
wait so he's not the only one so there
are how many times you think they had to
try this to make it look great I don't I
don't know I mean I'm sure they had a
case but that means that there were at
least three people with k or like
including Kid Rock where does he shoots
this way and there were there was
gunfire coming from the right of him so
once he's like loaded like this there's
gunfire coming this way and there's
another person that's filming so that's
how much of a little [__] ass [__] Kid
Rock is and triggered that he can only
he can't he can't even do it himself
right he needs someone else with
potentially more Firepower you know I
would love the ATF to take a little stop
over to Kid Rock's Ranch because I'm
kind of curious what automatic weapons
that guy has right that's what this is
this is the problem with the United
States right now you got people saying
we need to have fully automatic weapons
and having even semi-automatic weapons
we see what happened in Nashville and
then we see these these people these the
these people these students these
families these parents these
Representatives who are like we're
[__] fed up man like the fact that
you guys are okay with this and you're
now trying to pass and I think they did
just pass the fact that open carry
should be allowed for teachers like more
guns yeah right how are we solving
that's the opposite of what they want
that's the opposite a teacher's parents
communities that's the opposite of what
they want you think that if a bunch of
people showed up and they did to say hey
we don't want you to pass this we don't
want more guns we just saw what happened
in a school in a Grade School and
supposedly two of your staff members
also had guns and they didn't even stop
that [__] so you're gonna tell me right
now that you should put more guns in
schools those families those parents
those activists they stood up and said
no no we don't want that don't do that
and they're like huh
we don't actually have to listen to you
right and that's the [__] up thing
about the Republican party they think
that what they say is the word of God
and what they do is totally sinless the
craziest thing is that um Marjorie
Taylor green said it and several others
the thing that stopped that bad guy with
a gun in the school was a good guy with
gun yeah well it should have stopped
well before that right the fact we
didn't have to we didn't have to take
those three children's lives those three
teachers lives nor the gunman the the
person with the gun's life we don't have
to keep doing this we don't have to keep
doing this this is the thing we do not
have to keep doing and that's what those
people in Tennessee are there for to be
loud about that and the Republicans use
that as an opportunity to get rid of the
two black members that they don't like
right exactly it's the craziest part
that's the craziest part to me I mean is
that they thought the people that are
yelling and screaming outside going we
notice you we see what's happening we're
telling you what we want and like you
know what let's use this opportunity to
get rid of the two black guys we don't
like they won't notice like what the
[__] are you serious you can hear them
outside of the chambers you can hear
them chanting and you're like oh you
know what because the door is closed No
One's Gonna know what we did tonight
yeah they're not gonna know this they're
not gonna catch on to what we're doing
when we vote out the two black members
but the white lady will keep her yeah
they're not gonna notice that by one
vote Yeah by one I think the difference
was it was uh and it was Pearson's vote
you know that right he was on the floor
voting because he wasn't expecting
expelled yet that's right he was the
last one expelled so he was the vote
that kept Pearson all right
kept Johnson which is interesting when
like I know obviously there's like a few
white guys they're like all right we
gotta love the white lady you know and
even you know and good on Johnson for
being like look there's only one
difference between us I mean it's pretty
pretty apparent right I'm uh I'm an
older white lady and yeah even the white
lady's like hey look I mean I'm glad I'm
not expelled but Jesus Christ come on
are you kidding me well it's kind of
obvious why I got picked not to be
expelled I mean it's obvious and they
counted votes they counted votes they
knew they had the votes they knew what
votes they had they knew she wasn't
going to be expelled they knew it but
also they still did this I know I know
and if you think about it the fact that
she was saved by Pearson's one vote it's
almost like did you guys think this
through like if you really wanted to
[__] this up for for all three of them
right when you have expelled the points
too that's the point that's the point is
they knew they knew what the votes were
going to come down on her right and
that's why they ex they expelled Jones
first her second and him third they did
they did not think this through of how
they were gonna do it they just didn't
think through what the contest were
consequences are going to be and I'm
we're gonna come back from break we're
gonna go to bonehead of the week here
because that's what bonehead of the week
is about because yeah bunch of [__]
boneheads in Tennessee we got a few
outliers there or the dishonorable
mention yeah yeah and an outfit and one
of them one of them the DM there's an
update on him this morning yes there is
he made a statement apparently about it
it's so dumb what an idiot
I mean the boneheads just keep on coming
so folks stick around because we're
gonna do bonehead of the week when we
come back from this break
um it's top of the hour like we normally
do for one hour and that's what Gabe's
got here so we're gonna do it today and
it's pretty much going to be about
Tennessee so don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after these messages
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
wait was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slim Jims skull
near run out daddy light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again years
Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the lived love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
[__] em [__] em [__] em we're back to
the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
we got a lot of fun
I wonder if he uh
Bob and Tammy are from Tennessee I don't
know maybe
maybe they could be from Tennessee I
think it's possible bonehead of the week
I think they could be I mean look if you
have to be like hey where do they live
in magaland it's just any one of those
spots right they vacation in Tennessee
but they live in Florida or you know
stupid [__] like that right right well I
mean Obama Tammy definitely cool from
Tennessee they could be yeah they could
be I think hey look they could have been
look we'll say it this way they they
were born and they met in Tennessee and
they moved to Florida and now they go
back you know they go you know what
they're probably going to go back uh
this weekend for Easter you know
celebrate Easter with the family
Tammy is from he is he is from Alabama I
mean they could be from Alabama no no it
could be from Missouri too I mean it all
kind of Blends together
well I mean
look I mean there's a lot of a lot of
people in control down there who are
bigots doing some very shitty things
right and you all kind of blend together
and be like look if you want your own
bigot country
if you want to succeed I guess you can
if you want I mean you'll be [__] over
because you don't get the actual support
you need from the blue States but
whatever
whatever's floats your boat we're gonna
get into bonehead of the week here let's
get to it because I I gotta I wanna
I want to see what the DM and alpha is
to here we got that to go through but
we're that most of this bonehead's going
to be Tennessee so let's get into a
bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
bonette of the week when I was sending
you the names because we're trying to
like figure out who to put on the pool
I'm like this [__] this
[__] no this [__] like I
can I can confirm in the text Tony was
like Yep this [__] and at first
I didn't realize what you're the first
guy you sent yeah it was a clip and I
was like oh I didn't see this part of
the thing I was like Wow or like whoa or
something like that and then you're like
this [__] I was like oh I see
what he's doing now okay
this is who's gonna be on the ball these
because usually I I I gave Sanchez is
normally the one yeah yeah it's the pole
and he's like what do you think and I'm
like hey here's my thoughts and he might
change it but yesterday I was like nope
these three [__] right here
these white wrinkly old ball sacks are
the one we're putting on this pole
um and I actually am not surprised by
who won because he's kind of the
standout has been the standout yeah um
for some time for the last week
um where the Speaker of the House Sexton
Cameron Sexton as it is he has stood in
the way of these protests um he's the
one that caused the happenings in the
well because he wouldn't give Democrats
the ability to speak on the floor he
wouldn't give them the ability to speak
on the floor now because he controls the
chamber as the speaker with the rules
that they've set so they can silence
Democrats I wonder if these uh Tennessee
Republicans are for cancel culture and
for the First Amendment right of people
I would say they want to protect their
First Amendment right and they want to
cancel everything but themselves what do
you think I mean if you're white yeah
you're right it's all right you know I
mean that's really what it is yeah
because I think you sent me last night
when I sent you that clip you're like
sounds about white
to me I think that's what you said yeah
and then I sent the other ones I'm like
this [__] and this [__]
oh I see you're doing the poll like yeah
you're doing the policy I was I was
first thinking well this guy's a [__]
bag but also so you were just being like
yeah here are the people that we should
put on the list well here's here's the
boneheads and it should just be like
across the board Tennessee Republicans
in the legislative they'd be but we have
to pick three yeah so we have no there
were some Republic weren't there some
Republicans who voted no or was that
only for Johnson that's only for Johnson
uh representative Andrew farmer here oh
there's a good clip on this guy
representative Cameron Sexton he's the
speaker of the house there and
representative Geno bolso [__] yeah
a bunch of [__] our our contestants
on bonehead of the week
these [__] guys so let's start with
farmer let me start with this uh clip
from yeah what clip you got let's see uh
well you know actually you know what
[__] these guys you know what I I you
know what [__] these guys I actually
don't want to show the clips of that I
want to show the clips of Jones yeah
you're trying to be quite honest I think
they're the heroes of the day [__] these
boneheads they voted for them because
they were black and they don't like
these black members let me show you why
they don't like Justin Jones now this is
all the way back I believe in uh 2000
let me make sure I don't want to be
wrong is this the one that's from like
two thousand twenty twenty July 2020
Tennessee holler put this up he said
flashback July 2020. I got another
flashback for you too okay yeah send
that one to me
um this is Brother Jones now he's
they're in they're in the Capitol here
and it was the one of the first rallies
to remove the KKK statue or the bust of
the KKK member
um that that they eventually removed
um and and it was the beginning of
what tennis the Tennessee legislator
knew of Justin's Jones and his activism
now since then he became a
representative that had that represents
part of Nashville itself but here's the
video
um from that 2021 rally
I believe
everybody
now when I seen this clip this this
morning Gabe Sanchez what I realized
what I realized is that fascist you know
we were joking the other day and I think
someone said we should make [__]
whistles yeah because you know on the
whistles you could even put this this
whistle kills fascism right fascists are
terrified of sound they are oh terrified
like like if you get loud if you get it
you know and I always wonder what why I
triggered these fascists and I I was I
was like you know what that's what it is
like if we look at Margaret Taylor green
as an example right Margaret Taylor
green loves to yell and scream when it's
her own when it's her own voice right
which is interesting because uh like I a
lot of people tend to not like their own
voice they just don't like the way that
it's sounds when I hear it
um that's definitely not me I am just
saying Marjorie green right she will
harass people scream at people yell at
them on the street right and then at the
Trump arraignment on Tuesday
she got into a car with her boyfriend
Brian Glenn and was like ah my ears um
you know it's actually uh assault by
whistle
um they're blowing these whistles and
it's very damaging to your ears and also
it's illegal in New York City
it's not illegal it is not illegal not
at all and also the fact that this woman
who normally assaults others with
auditory uh
ways we'll say is now complaining that
the whistles right we're causing damage
I mean she did when she visited I think
it was most recently when they went to
go see the Jan six uh prisoners right
and it was revealed that it was kind of
this like oh little field trip and then
you were like oh actually the conditions
that these people are in are pretty nice
considering they're in the newer
facility
and when you see margin Hiller green
there was somebody whistling at that
press conference they had outside and
she was like oh and there's somebody
whistling she didn't have a problem then
she didn't know the problem then because
there weren't more people whistling and
there were more people yelling to get
the [__] out of New York City right so
Barbara makes a point here in that video
if anyone couldn't understand what they
were chanting I believe we will win I
believe we will win that's what they
were chanting and that's why that's why
the Republicans the racist Republicans
in Tennessee are terrified of Justin
Jones because not only did he win that
battle he won his [__] race he became
represented part of their legislative
body a guy who stands on the bull arm
and creates sound and creates a movement
and creates people
who will help him make change they're
terrified of that you can't whoa you
can't be loud and black at the same time
here in Tennessee it's you got to be one
or the other
um so they were chanting I believe we
will win I'm gonna point something out
here because you're just talking about
triggering Republicans about being
browned
he's admitting it he is so triggered
Dustin says he's so triggered dude
you're here every day like triggered by
everything that we say you stupid [__]
you know there's a there's a part of me
when I see when I see people come on you
know and try to clown and Troll and
stuff yeah you know it's like it's funny
because I feel like
a lot of these people are kind of like
masochists right they like the
punishment they like being talked spoken
to they like making it a fool of
themselves and embarrassing I mean look
the whole party is a completed
embarrassment if you're trying Dustin
here wants to talk about how oh this is
not a violation of someone's First
Amendment right you know to use the go
the the government the the local state
government's powers to suppress the
voice by expelling two members
of the house you're gonna tell me that
that's okay
well I mean their crime here if you if
you watch yesterday when they when
they're when the Republicans suspended
the rules to play the video their crime
here is that they were in the well for
10 seconds
before the the house they look look we
broke the Quorum we admit that you know
and right they never said what what
they're claiming they did they didn't do
I mean this is Dustin I know you're
you're because you're always triggered
in here dude so this might trigger you
this is like when um Marjorie Taylor
green or Lauren brobert's dumbass speaks
up in a Committee hearing when they're
not recognized
and and then they are finally get
recognized so they can speak it's the
same it's the same [__] it's the same
thing it's the same thing you just don't
like it and you're triggered Dustin
because you're always triggered dude
that's the only thing you do is I come
here every day and talk into a
microphone and you're so triggered by it
you got to be triggered the whole
[__] two hours you're like trigger
gotta comment some oh I'm triggered
gotta come Tony triggered me got a
comment something [__] loser look I'm
so yeah well yeah I'll say what I'm
gonna say after yeah
Okay the reason why you're so triggered
is because
Jones
and Pearson are black dudes that's why
you're [__] upset because they have
power and voices for their [__]
constituents and you don't want them to
speak for their constituents because
they're black go with it man I was just
gonna say Dustin over here you know he
always comes on the show and I Gotta
Give it to Dustin because Dustin really
is this person who comes on the show
every day and really you know he showed
you know he he shows his his cards right
he's like oh I'm uh I'm a racist I'm a
bigot I'm a transpho uh I'm a fascist
right and Dustbin you know really has
this inability to just stop and look at
what the Republican party is doing right
you don't see Democrats trying to expel
to people who spoke up for gun violence
to say hey maybe we've had enough huh
but I gotta know Dustbin over here I got
I mean sorry Dustin is someone who just
can't
can't just accept the fact that the
Republican party is not great but
Dustbin is I I would say an amazing an
amazing fan of the show because he comes
here every day right Dustin comes here
every day
thank you Dustin thank you Dustin thank
you Dustin okay and thanks for the
Facebook algorithm by the way when you
oh yeah then oh man it really pops off
over there this is really going to
trigger you Dustin uh be prepared this
is a picture here
um and this is seven years ago yeah and
and if you see the young man standing
here in the suit and tie uh do you
recognize who that is
that is representative Justin Jones
brother Jones as he's known on Twitter
and um they're standing here uh and I
believe this was what was this for he
was trying to get some sort of activism
here yeah this was uh it was seven years
ago and this popped up on someone's
Facebook feed and it is oh they were
advocating for Medicaid expansion which
Tennessee Republicans the fascist the
Dustin's butt buddies over there love to
make sure that people in Tennessee don't
get the Medicaid funding the federal
government allocates for them right it's
it's really dumb stuff and he was there
advocating that poor folk in the state
of Tennessee would receive those federal
funds from the ACA of Medicaid and
expanding it and here he is all the way
back seven years ago so this guy's not
new to this right I mean it's like when
many times when you're like oh man that
actor they just came up they like poof
they were on the scene right it's like
no it takes years it takes years right
and just like this like activism it just
takes that one moment that one moment
that projects you on the national stage
and a lot of the times it's you know uh
with the help of the Republican party
because they do something and then
somebody speaks out and it goes viral
right and this was one of those things
like nobody I would say I mean maybe
within Tennessee in the Nashville area
you know brother Jones right but outside
of the shooting that happened and
speaking up to say hey we don't need
more guns in schools we need just better
smarter more restrictive laws on guns so
less people die again not a radical not
a crazy idea just the fact that we want
to have our communities more safe by
limiting the amount of guns and who they
can go to right but before this no one
probably knew who who brother Jones was
right especially outside of Tennessee
right now everyone [__] knows like
you said not only on a national stage
but everyone and you're watching all
around the world is watching typically
like oh this guy stood up to say we
shouldn't have more gun violence and the
Republicans like ah [__] that [__] you
are expelled and everyone in the world's
like whoa whoa what why why and and the
world's like okay it looks a little
obvious is when you expel the the two
black dudes but not the white woman and
speaking of that here is here's all
three members who were put up for a vote
to be expelled yesterday of course you
have um representative Jones here going
to speak yeah Pearson uh on his right
and and Gloria Johnson on his left here
um this is um this is I I believe this
is after uh Pearson and yeah these were
expelled yeah um but let's listen to
some of the words that Jones says
because it's not just that they expelled
two young black men like these dudes
aren't dumb right yeah they're not and
they're very they're really really good
speakers and I I was surprised I
probably shouldn't have been but I was
very surprised
when
Jones could just pull scripture out of
anywhere as soon as these Republicans
were asking really stupid questions he's
like oh really what about your
Christianity dummy it was it was [__]
amazing and if you haven't went and
watched that portion of his 20-minute
speech and then the question answer
afterwards that the speaker allowed
which I really don't understand why
Republicans did that they should have
just brought him up expelled them and
[__] let them leave like don't show
the world yeah
you guys are coming up and trying to
trying to own them in this situation and
it looks and what you're doing is you
just gave them a platform to you know
nobody interrupt like they the ability
to not be interrupted and be like look
I'm going to give this speech and I'm
gonna deliver it exactly how I want and
emphasize the points that I want and you
can't say [__] right and then there's
like okay if you want to come up and say
something or whatever the Republican
Party said something it's like all right
you guys said something now I have the
ability to respond and I'm gonna call
you out and say why that is dumb as [__]
right well they did this all um under
the guise of suspending the rules
because that's what the video was and
they had to suspend the rules because
the videos the way they claimed it
violated the rules so they had to
suspend the rules to show the video
which brought the issue to emotion but
here here is afterwards um outside uh
the capital there where they're rallying
let's listen to the words of brother
Jones
democracy today
a party a a caucus that is majority
rights that one member was a little bit
confused
the two youngest black lawmakers
for standing with our constituents for
demanding that we take action on the
crisis of mass shootings yeah
he said we want to ban on the soul
weapons they said we're going to solve
the democracy
damn we want to ban on assault weapons
and they want to dude I gotta tell you
the last couple of weeks man
when it comes to gun violence you know
we had you know dead kids can't read
and this is the assault on Democracy
like these lines I mean
are pretty good and and I think and I
want to in some ways I want to thank the
Republican party because again they're
allowing the the Democrats or anyone on
the left to highlight the double
standard the hypocrisy the projection of
the Republican party and calling them
out and there are these perfect [__]
zingers that they're delivering right
now that I'm sure I'm sure will continue
on
and be used in ads or political
campaigns or speeches because they
[__] sting and they and they really
do land the the point they're trying to
make they do well and you know I was
just thinking about this because someone
typed in
um it was Karen here she says in memory
of John Lewis good trouble let me tell
you something I it made me think of our
interview with Senator Doug Jones yeah
of the former Center of Alabama the
other day about how he wants to bring
the Democratic National Convention to
Atlanta and I I'm telling you this is
going to be
um a fight now I want to show you this
and this goes right along with good
trouble
um this is moments and if you keep an
eye on right up here
um or just over the balcony there's
going to be a banner up here here this
is just the moments after uh
representative Pearson so he was the
third one of a vote to expel
um of course he was expelled from the
legislator there with that vote now his
vote was a little less than um
representative uh Jones and that's one
reason why it's because they're scared
of Jones I've been scared of him for a
while because he's from Nashville and
he's been an activist there at the
Nashua capital for a while but pay
attention to what this Banner says here
uh as it's hung over the balcony when
Pearson moments after he is voted to
expect watch
thank you
you see it there do you see what it says
Gabe it says rule Tennessee against
fascist GOP it says rule Tennessee
against fascist GOP now watch what
happens to it almost the moment that it
comes up there
[Applause]
can't let people see them they
they want people to see that rural
Tennessee is against the fascist GOP I
mean tell me another reason why two
black men were expelled and a white lady
saved you know right she was I think the
the
though I think it was on Fox news and it
was Sexton was given an interview and
he's like I didn't expel them because
they're black
and the language that that they did what
he said that yeah I'm pretty find that
[__] clip because I got another clip
I'm gonna show of that answer but in in
there in the graphic on Fox News it was
like expelled expelled spared right and
you're like oh yeah spare the white lady
like the language we're using here and I
don't know if that's the right way to
say expelled or not expelled or whatever
but like oh man she was saved she should
be so grateful that because you know
like that's the this she was pissed yeah
it was pissed rightfully I'm gonna show
you a clip of her she was pissed here
said Joy Joanne reads um take of H.R 63
that was brought up by one of our
boneheads uh Mr farmer Andrew farmer I'm
gonna play a clip of that [__] here
in a moment
um but this is the motion to adopt of
the expulsion so watch watch Joanne's
reads um explanation of this and see if
you can catch where she's going that was
uh
to expand Bell represents Tennessee
representative Tennessee state
representative Justin Pearson after he
preached a whole sermon and I will note
that that Justin Jones that you saw on
the screen that was not us that was not
MSNBC not only did this state
legislature vote out Justin Pearson a
duly elected state representative who
was elected by more than 70 000
constituents they couldn't even get his
name right they confused Justin Jones
for Justin Pearson and put the wrong
name up that was the feed that we were
taking from Tennessee so we had to write
name up that was Justin Pearson if you
all are going to do wrong and you're
going to do evil please at least get
these brothers names right they're two
different people learn to tell them
apart you're telling on yourself racism
is Alive and Well in the state where the
Ku Klux Klan was born
she says oh God damn dude she was like
I'm gonna I'm gonna take off my news
anchor voice for a moment here and I'm
gonna let you [__] hear what I have
to say and dude she's not wrong man
Joanne greed is not wrong on this he's
like you guys the fact because it's the
whole argument like oh well you all look
the same what's the difference right and
I was like oh boy that what you guys
have done right there you you guys are
[__] just saying the quiet part out
loud right the idea that you guys can't
you guys don't want these these uh these
two guys inside the house but not only
that but you don't even respect them
enough to get their names right right
whether you did it intentionally or not
it doesn't matter
you guys are so [__] terrible you
guys are absolute boneheads and the
reason why you guys are on the list this
week the fact that they're you know it's
just it's just [__] insane man to see
this [__] happen in real time right
because again like I said earlier this
is not gonna stop these two people right
it's not gonna stop them at all if
anything they have activated two people
that were already activists right that
were already out there fighting for the
will of the people fighting for their
constituents fighting for the for the
parents who lost their children uh in in
the in the Covenant School shooting but
also before that right you know brother
Jones talked about he was I I think it
was during he's like I don't know if
she's here right now but there's a
mother who also lost her child right and
she I'm I'm here representing her right
that is what I'm doing I'm protesting
the parents and the family members who
have lost their family members right
right forbid we just take a moment to
actually consider maybe the these deaths
aren't warranted right we could stop
this well the other thing too that
Republicans really did wrong here
um is they activated Gloria Johnson
right yeah I think they thought oh well
she'll be grateful she'll move on she's
not gonna Embrace these two she's white
and that is not what happened at all
like you only you you you made many
mistakes by doing what you did and the
imagery but the imagery of keeping the
white woman and then the actual Act of
because I don't know if anyone knows who
Gloria Johnson is but we've showed
several clips of Gloria Johnson on the
show before because of her stance and
her being one of the only [__]
in the Tennessee legislator
who who can speak to her [__] right
as a woman to her health care and it's
done it time and time again I think we I
think we played two clips before
of Gloria Johnson standing up for
women's right to health care and trans
people's right to exist I believe if I
go back and look
um she's no she's no non-fighter
yeah and they only they so not only did
they have the the obvious
the obvious imagery that they were
expelling using this excuse to expel two
black members that they don't like
because they're black and they're
activists but they only they only
gave Gloria Johnson more reason to fight
and here is a um a video yesterday of
her and a representative Justin Jones
watch this this is powerful
these folks may not have paid attention
but America is gonna go that guy is a
rock store
and I'm so sorry
[Applause]
thank you
Gloria
[Applause]
[Music]
you will be the check on their power in
there and we're going to keep fighting
it so it was so nice to have somebody to
fight with me for the first time
but I will keep fighting for you all I
won't stop
so they haven't only activated
these two are propelled these two
activists to be National icons like you
said right now they they've only
solidified Gloria Johnson's resolve to
fight against these fascists in the
Tennessee Republican party yeah like
what are you I mean really you every
move you make is the exact opposite move
that's gonna get you where you want to
be like this is not going in your
direction and you're the perpetuator of
this like literally all's the
Republicans in Tennessee had to do right
all they really had to do is what
Republicans always do right they could
have said oh there's huge protests we
gotta calm this down so let's let's meet
let's have a public meeting with
Democrats let's talk about red flags and
and background checks why we don't do
anything about it the calm the
temperature right to kind of kind of
make the issues simmer and go away right
normally what Republicans try to do they
say things like they say well this isn't
the time this is yeah you know yeah the
the time the time right now are just
thoughts and prayers right you can't
rush right to the legislator that's
right to make these decisions we can't
work we can't be in haste we have to
heal we have to heal you know is there
language right and they could have done
that typical thing but they did not do
that here in Tennessee they responded to
the to the Tennessee protest almost as
if there's this angst of Revenge that
Republicans want to place on people who
just want democracy in this country
right just want the rule of law they
want someone to listen to their voice
almost and they're and and they're
almost seeking Revenge it's almost feels
like Gabe Sanchez what we've been
talking about so much it's to own the
libs it was to own those liberal black
activists that happened to win
congressional seats that they don't like
it's it it's the fact that you know
it goes beyond the owning of the lips
right it goes to a point where the
Republican Party
You know despite the fact that a lot of
the party is just a [__] clown show
right we got
you know we got a [__] former
president who's uh
[__] going to trial for committing uh
crimes also being investigated in other
things you've got these people who are
showing up to New York right you've got
people who are who are showing up
um in any situation wherever these
people speak right these Republicans to
say like oh you know what we're going to
take away uh the rights of trans kids in
schools because us parents are triggered
on behalf of our children right we're
the we're the people who show up and and
think that we should be removing CRT and
social emotional learning and all this
[__] because it's actually an
indoctrination of the woke left trying
to get inside our children's brains you
know
and and these Republicans
you know I've said it before they've
jumped they've jumped the shark right
they jumped that woke shark they think
everything is woke everything is is in
his attack against them right uh they
think that anything that is the opposite
of what they think is a threat to their
understanding of what democracy is right
but really they are the problem they are
they're the ones who are making this
worse and they are now you know before I
think maybe they could have gotten away
with stuff if they slowed it down right
they really kind of like elongated this
out and was like yeah we'll get to it
you know like we'll make these baby
steps to a fascist right type of regime
it could happen with them they could
have had that right they could have done
all kinds of things for all of these
different things whether it's a school
uh you know shootings uh you know the
trans Community uh whatever it might be
like [__] Banning books right
the Republican Party decided hey you
know the best time to do all this right
now at the same time everything just
[__] throw it in right and instead of
you know them being like yeah let's
let's hold off we'll do one thing at a
time we'll get there eventually we'll
play the long game they're like no no we
got to play it right now we see the
threat of this younger generation right
uh women who are [__] like no you're
not taking away my bodily autonomy uh
we're [__] done with it I you know
I'm with the Republican party but I'm
not willing to stand with you while you
guys on this I'm moving away and the
Republic is like oh we got to do
everything now we have to take it all
away
and I think people are seeing that
and and they're calling it out and the
Republican party is like oh [__] well in
order the only way for us to stop this
from infecting right our state of
democracy like in Tennessee is we got to
get rid of them we got to remove them
right right and that's exactly what they
went to do and I'm going to show you a
video of Andrew farmer here one of our
boneheads I'm not going to get to all of
it because Gabe Sanchez has to go but at
at the top of the hour so I'm gonna get
moving here here is Andrew Farmer see if
you can pick out for me and then Pearson
responds here but see if you can pick
out to me why farmer wants
um these two young these two young black
men expelled let's see if you can find
it
for that yearning to have attention
that's what you wanted
but you're getting it now
so I just advise you
if you want to conduct business in this
house follow Bill be recognized stand
there and present it and pass it all you
gotta do is pass a bill
foreign
it almost feels like to me he wanted to
call him something there oh you you
absolutely know he did he he almost like
he had one more word that he wanted to
say right I don't know exactly what the
word is I mean I do but I mean I I feel
like he had one more word that he wanted
to say into the mind so people people
are saying uh the volume so just to
summarize what he said farmer was like
look if you guys want to speak up right
if you want to say something introduce a
bill introduce a bill don't get up and
do what you guys did you can you can say
what you want to say but if you do it
with the bill translation
if you want to get up and talk again
right you do it under the way that we
say you should do it right you do it
when we say it's appropriate so sit down
vote
but if you get up and you speak out and
get all uppity on me uppity I'm gonna
come after you right and the fact that
he's like he's like look he's like you
got to respect you you gotta respect it
this thing like shut the [__] up man
farmer is a racist who is using his
position to control the voice and
suppress the voice of two black men
inside that inside that chamber right
the idea that farmer is threatened by
two black men two young black men who
have a future a [__] amazing future
especially now right right but the idea
that farmers like look I mean to your
point like a wanted to say something I'm
sure I'm sure behind closed doors or
when he's with his buddies you know in
the smoking room I'm sure he's dropping
that hard R all the time oh hell you
know farmer with the hard R right oh
[__] that is what he's doing and that is
what he's saying because he feels
threatened he he can't accept the fact
that there is a younger generation there
is a whole new movement that's happening
he's like no no we got to keep things
the way they were if you want to talk
then you do it the way that we say you
do it well watch how Pearson responds
here and how he talks this is wow just
wow watch
we and you are seeking to expel District
86's representation from this house
in a country that was built on a protest
[__]
um you who celebrate July 4th 1776.
hot fireworks and eat hot dogs
you say to protest is wrong
because you spoke out of turn
because you spoke up for people who are
marginalized you spoke up for children
who won't ever be able to speak again
you spoke up for parents who don't want
to live in fear you spoke up for for
Larry Thorne who was murdered by gun
violence you spoke up with people that
we don't want to care about
in a country built on people who speak
out of turn who spoke out of turn who
fought out a turn to build a nation
I come from a long line of people who
have resisted
so let me tell you something um
[Music]
I wonder if anyone spotted why
the white Christian nationalist in the
home of the KKK there in Tennessee the
real America First Republican Nazis
inside the Tennessee legislator I wonder
why they're scared of Justin Pearson
here it seems like to me they could be
scared that this young black man is so
powerful in the way he speaks and the
way he forms ideas yeah and they're
terrified of those ideas getting out
into the public right almost like they
want to cancel those ideas and ban those
ideas more than they want to ban guns
and they definitely don't like the fact
that you know they gave them they gave
them that platform right again this is
this is Republican like one
republicanism 101 you try to own the
libs
and what ends up happening is they
[__] face plant
on this whole tribe like oh we're gonna
oh man we got you on this one boom fall
right on their face right them trying to
[__] ban Bud Light and shoot these
cans because it's because they're God
forbid they're hey we should we should
be accepting of the LGBT the side note
there did you know that Bud Light has
has been in cooperation with glad since
like 1999. yeah like
this has been two goddamn decades but
before inbev even bought even bought
Anheuser Bush that but like realized
that equity and equality is a good thing
but the lgbtq community drink beer like
what the [__] is wrong with you I mean
I'm watching videos of these people like
this is to really show you is like you
watch these videos of these Republicans
who get all upset about you know oh man
this whoa this woke that right it's
exactly what these people are doing in
this chamber right here these these
these white guys like oh no you can't be
woke can't talk about that you know so
whether it's the the beer right or the
books or the drag shows or you know the
the [__]
uh kids who just want to play sports
right like it's any of this stuff it's
all the threat to their way of life that
right their their condition
that they believe they should be uh they
they should be just have themselves
right they they don't want they don't
want these different non-white
non-straight people in their lives right
you know they're it's it's amazing to
see and also believable to see the
Republican Party
use their power
against someone that they could work
with right
but when they see
this moment right because again to bring
it back it backfired on them because
they're like look we'll give you this
platform we'll let you talk we'll let
you speak right give you know as a as a
as a case right as a trial we'll let you
speak right now to make your case we're
already gonna vote a certain way so it's
already been determined we know how
we're going to vote right
but we'll let you speak
and again the Republican Party face
plants on the idea that oh we own the
Libs no what you did was
you project you you you you projected
these these people this movement this
topic of what it's been about to expose
yourselves
as Hypocrites racists or overall bigots
or apathetic human beings or you know
cold-hearted DNA uh uh you know uh uh
just
I don't know what I want to call him
really but the people who are who feel
that they have to they're beholden to
the NRA right nra-backed people these
are the people that they don't care
about other people they don't care about
Americans their constituents they don't
care about uh
uh saving lives or protecting the rights
of others and when anyone ever when and
whenever someone brings that up right
whatever someone brings that up
they feel threatened
and I'm just I'm just up there are
snowflakes they're snowflakes I'm just
surprised that they were that they gave
them the opportunity to speak because it
only further showed that the Republican
Party
is these two-faced hypocritical bigoted
racists who only work by the behest of
the the lobbyist money right
well it is King inside the Republican
party and so is lies inside the
Republican party and which brings us to
our dishonorable mention and we'll come
back to speaker Sexton here in a moment
but our dishonorable mention is Matt art
excuse me let's do our Alpha cut first
Matt taibi that's where I want to go
fight wait hold on I just want to people
keep saying they're looking for the
emotes in twitch I'm going to work on it
this weekend I just haven't had a time
this week so I I've heard it I've seen
it
I will work on it I promise I promise so
here here is um
here's our Alpha [__] Matt taibi
um and idiot
you're talking nude you said something
about face planting earlier holy this
guy I mean him and Elon Cody were like
oh we're gonna get a man we're totally
we're totally gonna get him
um but they they didn't do that
uh yeah they actually got schooled on
national television it was beautiful it
was beautiful because oh my God there's
like two or three Clips I can show which
one you want me to show is the the one
where he um the one where he's on the
show yesterday
yeah but should I should I show it the
one where he's like the the Elon Musk I
don't uh no I don't particularly want to
um to criticize him do you want me to
play the clip where he says well yeah
that's an error or do you want me to
play the clip I mean there's so many
good Clips play the play the clip play
the clip where he says he admits to the
error because there's a follow-up and
then I'll show you my tweet uh that you
can show but it was a
show that clip
because I think that's gonna be be more
impactful for this okay so let's let's
play a little bit of this exchange you
talk a lot about the election Integrity
project in the Twitter files which
Stanford and the University of
Washington founded to monitor attacks on
our elections
um and you say some stuff about them
that a lot of your critics say is not
true and that affects your credibility
you've said the EIP was founded in
response to the government dropping its
proposal for a disinformation
governments but there you are we're
quoting you on screen it wasn't it was
formed two years earlier you suggest it
was government funded even though during
the 20 election 2020 election that
you're covering it wasn't you say they
labeled 22 million tweets as
misinformation in the run-up to the 2020
vote they didn't uh they got they
flagged 3 000 election misinformation
tweets for labeling so you were only 21
million 997 000 off and you also put in
the EIP with let me finish the question
you can come back in you also claim the
EIP was partnered with the government
cyber security and infrastructure agency
sisa to send this to Twitter but you mix
up sisa cisa a homeland security agency
with the center for Internet Security
the CIS which is a non-profit in fact
you added an a to CIS I think people can
see it there uh in Brackets uh to make
that false claim it's just error after
error Matt on just this one
but the other but the other ones aren't
no no 22 million numbers came from their
own report yeah it came from reporting
do you know what the 22 million number
is Matt can you tell me because we
checked 22 million is the number of
tweets about election misinformation
that would just that they just mapped
how many tweets were they the ones they
actually flagged to Twitter before the
election 22 million came after the
election it wasn't in the run-up they
flagged 3 000. so you were off by 21
million 997. it's been a lot of things
I stand by my story you stand by what's
do you stand by 22 million we're flagged
in the run-up to the election even
though that number came in March 2021
which was after the election
no that's this came in their report
after the election which was about some
some total of tweets that they counted
on the election what they flagged to
Twitter was 2980 tweets I believe so
that's nowhere near 22 million one yeah
you've got something wrong you've got
sister wrong why did you add a okay Matt
why did you add a in square brackets do
you understand why people worry about I
actually got that
and why did you fix it I just checked
the Tweet before I came on air it's been
three weeks since it was flagged you why
not fix it do you not have editors but I
didn't realize that until now okay what
about the date you got the date wrong
when it was found you said it was
founded in response to the
disinformation board that was last year
well because Stamos is saying in in the
video that you know we were sort of
created to fill the gaps uh no that's
not what you say in the Tweet that's not
what you're saying yes I know it was
created in 2018. you say this is what
you say that it would the EIP was
created after the public uproar paused
the disinformation board that's wrong
you need to correct that as well don't
you
after the
that's what you take to quote you after
public uproar paused the orwellian
disinformation governance board Stanford
created the EIP that's wrong
well that's what they say I I I've
um
you don't need sources Matt you could
check the EIP website it says it was
created in 2020.
well that's the date that I just said
the disinformation board was 2022 mm-hmm
okay
all right well then that is an error
God what a [__] idiot okay so I I
want everyone to understand that the
Twitter files and and I don't know if
you just saw is all a bunch of [__]
it's just a bunch of [__] Russian
propaganda that was pumped through Elon
Musk to to Matt taibi so that way Donald
Trump could and Jim Jordan and Jim uh
Comer could make bones about it in the
United States House of Representatives
and spread their misinformation and
their lies in the House of
Representatives now why not one Democrat
was able to form enough questions and
form enough information to go at Matt
Tybee when that son of a [__] went and
before the [__] committees and
Democrats had a chance to question him
and make him look like a fool in front
of microphones then I don't know why but
it's been done now and let me tell you
something Matt taibi will never be
welcomed back into the world of
Journalism with us with a serious stroke
ever again he is a hack he's a [__]
liar he knows he's a liar and he is a
goddamn semp for for Putin Trump and
Elon yeah you might as well put Kanye in
there if Jim Jordan's gonna tweet it you
know what I mean so I saw some people
that were saying um what is the a in
Brackets right why does they so the
reason that's so important is because
sis CIS is the center for Internet
Security it's a non-profit okay
and what Matt taibi is intentionally
misleading about it is that's a
non-profit okay that's a global global
internet Community right of I.T
professionals who are thinking of how to
make the internet safe okay they're not
a government agency they're non-profit
what Matt taibi said is that it's the
sisa right so he knew what he was doing
because he put the [__] brackets
around the a if he's like oh oops I've
mistyped and I thought it was CIS or
whatever he intentionally did that right
and the reason is because sisa is the
cyber security infrastructure security
agency that is a government body now
what Matt taibi is trying to argue here
is he's saying the government
was uh was working with Twitter to
censor things that were being talked
about but that's not at all right
because the argument is he's saying oh
there were 22 million tweets about uh uh
um
about election fraud right or
misinformation right but that's that's
22 million tweets that mentioned it
right right but there were three
thousand and that report was made after
the fact right and the 3 000 tweets are
actually the tweets that were of of
subject to be talked about not by this
group 22 million is the Whole Net we're
like hey you mentioned misinformation
you mentioned this election interference
whatever that was part of that group
three thousand of those were the actual
ones that were like oh we had to spread
misinformation why does this matter Gabe
why does it matter because this this is
comes at the heart of it why does it
matter why Matt taibi is a [__] hack
and a liar because Matt taibi is a well
I mean his connections to Russia which
also connect to Elon Musk but it's
important because Elon Musk gave him
quote unquote unfettered access even
though we know that there were
constraints but he's using
mataibi to spread misinformation right
about how Twitter actually operated they
worked with government agencies because
government agencies say hey we would
like to help use your resources and then
hey for your time we will compensate you
like any contractor would this is not
new companies have been hired all the
time to do this especially when you're
asking them to use their resources their
employees because Twitter said no we
don't want to give you access right well
yeah the reason why is the things that
match it's more efficient when the
Twitter employees are getting the the
information that the government agency
needs it's more efficient I don't know
they know the platform they work for it
they build it for [__] and they can
make sure that nobody's doing something
they shouldn't be doing or has access to
something they shouldn't have access to
and this is Matt Thai coming back in
response to be like oh that wasn't fair
what happened so so this is him after
the interview this is his 17 hours ago
tweet is him saying like oh how can he
demand I comment on something I haven't
covered in relation to the interview
that he just did right right
uh when he repeatedly refused to address
errors his network uh affirmatively did
make but were exposed by Twitter file
reports Hamilton 68 which is some one of
the [__] numerous things that they
released that was debunked that doesn't
uh doesn't need addressing before
accusing others of a cop-out
now the reason this is relevant is Matt
taibi is playing victim and saying oh no
wait this isn't fair how can you imagine
like how much journalism you are a
journalist you dummy how can I come well
the reason is on boys he's like how can
I comment on something like how can you
come at me with something that I don't
know anything about right
and here's the evidence March 24th and
he says why don't you invite me on your
show to talk about it since you're so
absolutely sure of what I'll say guess
what he did guess what he did we just
saw a clip of him and there's more clips
of it there's more and I wish I could
play it which was two weeks two weeks
ago and and and their team at MSNBC
we're like great we got two weeks to
really go through this [__] and make
sure that we have everything because
we've researched it and we have a whole
team that have verified these the these
uh these lies right this this
misinformation that you're spreading and
we have it debunked and now he's like oh
well how can you ask me to dude this is
so unfair you you I can't just come on
the show and use uh assault me with this
and right assault me with facts that's
ridiculous you asked to go on the show
right you [__] idiot you asked to go
on the show hey we got another person
and I don't mean to move on but I got
yeah yeah we got another person who
can't handle the truth yesterday we
found out that a Supreme Court Justice
Justice Clarence Thomas was taking
millions and millions and millions of
luxury gifts vacations Resorts Yachts
airplane rides you name it meals who
knows maybe he was even given blow and
prostitutes I don't know these were in
foreign countries how am I supposed to
know maybe it's laptops hookers and blow
that Clarence Thomas got from this Texas
billionaire and today today he does what
did well
my colleagues said it was okay
is that really his argument
he's gonna make this is here I've I've
got the uh yeah I've got the actual
response that Clarence Thomas is
attempting to make to be like guys it
was all good it's all good he spent
Millions on me yeah it's great you know
I love to be pampered and no I did not
do it against uh you know ethical kind
of constraints he says was advised that
this sort of personal Hospitality I love
that I love that you know I love the
bribe bribe bribe personal Hospitality I
like the you know how they cover that up
there from close personal friends who
did not have business before the court
was not reportable listen listen it
doesn't matter what the law is it
matters it matters what your intent is
and what your intent looks like it is
Demi you may not have to report it but
now we see you you [__] idiot so now
we know why you weren't reporting it
probably I mean it's just a guess and
also like you're gonna tell me that
Clarence Thomas
was friends with this guy maybe their
friends really friends I don't really
care but the fact that he was like hey
come out for a weekend let's go on this
yacht we'll take this private jet we'll
have caviar all this stuff it's
important to remember who that Mega
donor is Harlan Crow okay private jets
luxury cruises lavish Resort vacations
all that [__] is this guy it involved
involved in politics at all oh you bet
you're a [__] ass he is ah surely not
surely they're just close friends that
like laptops hookers and blow I'm just
throwing that out you want to know a
couple other people who might be
considered close personal friends who's
that I don't know something by the name
of curse in cinema or Joe manchin right
democracy is is something that is we
have seen clearly at stake and whoever
is able to pay the most money is able to
win or hold on to democracy and the
Supreme Court the highest court in the
land that has for the most part finals
say on a lot of these things right
you're gonna tell me that a guy who just
happily being Clarence Thomas a sugar
daddy
is not going to ask for a favor later on
and say hey remember when I gave you
that private plane ride for just you and
Jenny and you guys wanted to go to these
islands and take my yacht here here here
here here and you know have fun in the
sun well now it's time to pay up okay
I'm coming back and I'm asking for a
favor and I might not ask explicitly but
I might I don't know mention a
conversation here and there or let my
political point of view be known and you
know we'll have a some branding a cigar
and we'll laugh about it and I might
bring it up again and again and again in
future occasions enough where I don't
know it's pretty known or you know
subliminally you know exactly the
position you should have and maybe I do
explicitly say because it gets to a
point where I have to say you know what
Clarence I need you to rule in favor or
not in favor of this bill or this this
case that is coming up before your court
free no one just does anything no no
billionaire is like look maybe the
billionaire doesn't have friends and
he's like I just want to buy friends
but no person
will willingly just give that stuff away
without without expecting something
something to be paid back on the back
end right well I mean maybe maybe he was
just expecting Clarence Thomas's wife
here Jeannie Thomas to pay for some
buses to go to January 6. I don't know
I'm just surprising I'm just saying I'm
just saying
um I got one we got we got one more
piece of business here on bonehead the
week before we go we've got the bonehead
of the week winner representative
Cameron Sexton he's a speaker of the
house there in Tennessee legislator I
want to play a lot of clips of him but
this is the clip I want to play and it
only has his voice in it but listen
yes I tell you it was a sad day on
Saturday all hope seem to be lost
representatives were thrown out of the
State House democracy seem to be at its
end seemed like the NRA and God
lobbyists might win
but oh that was good news for us I don't
know how long this Saturday in the state
of Tennessee might last but oh we have
good news folks we've got good news that
Sunday always comes
Resurrection is a promise
and it is a prophecy it's a prophecy
that came out of the cotton fields it's
a prophecy that came out of the lynching
tree it's a prophecy that still lives in
each and every one of us in order to
make the state of Tennessee the place
that it ought to be and so I've still
got home because I know we are still
here and we will never quit
Here Comes Here Comes the speaker
[Applause]
[Music]
out of order
we're voting on house resolution 63 all
those in favor vote
and there is the speaker Sexton saying
out of order out of order and you
goddamn right they're out of order you
goddamn right they're out of order and
the entirety the entirety of the
pro-democracy Coalition right now today
should be out of order anywhere and
everywhere they can get out of order get
out of line start being loud like
representative Pearson they're not gonna
quit and neither should we and I I want
to say Cameron Sexton I didn't have you
on my radar at the beginning of the week
for this bonehead of the week but boy
you really surely did just move right on
in there let's give him his due
[Music]
[Applause]
oh you racist piece of garbage Sexton
you [__] you we see you we see
you you bigoted fascist and I know Gabe
you have to go you're gonna have a heart
out here but folks stick around I got a
few more Clips I want to show you I just
I just didn't get to them so I'm going
to show you a few more Clips on my own
so so stick around stick around after
the music but Gabe thanks for joining us
Dave we got through bone of the week in
time I think we did it we did it you're
gonna be on time right yeah it is if I
don't keep you for a couple of years if
I don't just keep talking and have you
on yeah yeah yeah yeah or what I would
say before I will yeah if you want to go
we can we do it here yeah go ahead go
ahead okay all right no anyway before I
go
uh have a great weekend if you celebrate
Easter go for it right if you feel
[__] riled up resurrected like
Pearson just said [__] you know call
call your call your rep call your
Senator call like we should be we should
be activating and letting people know
exactly what like you know how we feel
we should be letting them know exactly
what our position is and let them
[__] you know hey man if you don't do
what I'm gonna what you should be doing
we should [__] primary you you know
you should be using your voice in any
way you can to act up and uh I just want
to say have a good weekend uh there'll
be a new what was that coming out later
today that'll be about uh Margaret
Taylor green George Santos Lindsey
Graham Donald Trump check it out you can
find on my patreon uh have a good
weekend
we'll see you it's been bone end of the
week stick around I'm gonna show you a
few more videos right after this
tailgate bye see you later Gabe Sanchez
bonehead
[Music]
[Applause]
bonehead of the week you just got me now
here I I wanted to show you a few more
videos I got a few more videos I want to
show you oh these are excellent some of
them have to do with the Tennessee
things some of them have to do with just
fascist hating loud noises but hate loud
noises let me uh let me show you this
one video here that I found oh I found
it and I love it I love this video
it is um what the hell's her name she's
a swimmer she's went to uh somewheres to
talk for turning points USA to spread
their [__] vile hate against uh trans
folks rightly Gaines is her name rightly
game have you heard of this I I I've
never heard of this stupid asses
um but um the students at uh
HSS where is this at where the [__] is
this at I don't know she went and spoke
but she's terrified I mean just
terrified
of loud noises so much so that she had
to have people escort her away from the
loud noises folks It's Time to Get Loud
and Brown look at this watch this
fascist run from noises
[Music]
[Applause]
God damn uh if you're if you're unaware
that gen Z is serious about this [__] I
don't know if you know that yet or not
but God damn they are serious about
being loud and having their megaphone on
there's nothing more that I like than
loud and proud real and raw democracy
that's what I love so I love that video
uh I think it's really funny that Riley
Gaines with their stupid [__] bigotry
and their backwards ways of thinking of
freedom and rights and how it works I I
actually think that this is going to be
more and more prominent
and bigots are gonna be scared more and
more of loud noises
and they should probably just get to
used to being and hearing loud noises
if they're scared of them they just
better get used to it because I have a
feeling over the next two years we're
gonna have a lot of loud noises in this
country as you try to [__] oppress
your fascism on everyone in this country
women trans people the lgbtq community
uh young people let me show you do you
remember Scott Walker I told you about
this in the first 30 minutes this
[__] piece of [__] this guy posted
this on his Twitter they're saying it
out loud they're saying out loud in
Wisconsin this week
in Wisconsin the pro-democracy Coalition
shows up to give Wisconsin its first
swing towards a liberal Court Supreme
Court in almost 25 years and the reason
why is because Republican legislators
and Republicans and every single one of
these states read our swing are trying
to go all in on taking away people's
rights
and gen Z and the pro-democracy
Coalition is not afraid to be loud about
it not only that they're not afraid to
[__] use their power of their ballot
and go vote you [__] fascist
out and I love it and there's nothing
better than to hear this [__] clown
look at this look at this screenshot you
remember this [__] you remember
this guy he was supposed to be
Republican president of the United
States guy couldn't he make it out of
Iowa get the [__] out of here you
[__] sludge ass jokes let's listen to
this little piece of [__] talk about
young voters and how he didn't want him
to vote because they're indoctrinated to
liberalism and Truth get the [__] out of
here with this [__] the larger issue
here we've seen a particularly Wisconsin
but across the country is younger voters
in Wisconsin oh the larger issue here is
younger voters oh my God it's almost
like we're allowing them to exercise
their right to vote
folks I don't I don't I I I know I said
this last year that they were going to
come after trans children to take away
your parental consent away from you from
your children and they're doing it all
across the country they're doing it
they're doing it they're using Banning
books to try to take away your [__]
right for your child to get a public
education in this goddamn country
they're using it Scott Walker is
terrified that young people are are bone
to this they know it they hear it they
see it and they're voting against it
and he doesn't like it he doesn't like
that they're indoctrinated to The Truth
Listen to this piece of [__] Johnson
last fall we saw about a 40-point margin
now that younger voters gave to the
Democrats running for Senate and
governor who saw similar margins in
Pennsylvania part of the reason why you
have John fetterman and U.S Senate in
Arizona and Georgia elsewhere and just
this week in Wisconsin we don't yet know
the numbers by age but we do know that
Dane County uh which is where the
University of Wisconsin's Flagship
campus is at about 50 000 students are
enrolled there Dane County cast more
ballots in the race for the Supreme
Court than the largest county in the
state Milwaukee County and in Dane
County 82 percent of those votes went
for the radical and so unless we turn
young people around and it's not as
simple as one campaign ad or some sort
of a coalition this is years of liberal
indoctrination coming home to roost and
we've got to turn it around if we're
going to win again
they're telling you the quiet part out
loud well man they know the truth these
people know the [__] truth they can
read and we need to ban the books we
need to ban education we need to make
these [__] younger kids dumber and
not be able to vote these [__] idiots
run it to the point every single time
the reason why young people are voting
against you is because you're [__]
bigots and they don't like [__]
racist fascist ass bigots
stop doing what you're doing and do the
opposite and these [__] young folks
will vote for Republicans but you're not
gonna do that
Scott Walker you're not gonna do that
Jesus Christ I bet Scott Walker Got a
Boner yesterday when he saw two black
men being expelled from the state
legislator in Tennessee
I bet he got a chub
I'm not [__] you I bet he did I bet
he's like oh baby and he doesn't even
realize
he doesn't even realize that they have
awoken they always talk about woke oh
we're so scared of woke woke this woke
that what's wrong with this it's whoa
what's wrong with that it's what Bud
Lights woke Eminems are woke Disney's
woke it's all whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
woke well guess what
you dumb [__]
have awoken a sleeping giant
of course gen Z is woke you woke him up
with your loud ass bigotry you dumb sons
of [__] I don't see how they can't
see this stuff I just don't okay there's
a couple more Clips I want to show you
then we're gonna have to head out for
the weekend let me see if I can find
them
[Music]
oh boy
this um
this stuff down in Tennessee has got me
fired up for democracy I'm I am proud to
see that people are standing behind
these representatives in Tennessee and
I'm I'm proud to see that the country is
waking up to what is actually going on
and how the Republicans are using these
opportunities uh to take advantage of
our democracy
here is here's one from March Of Our
Lives this is a chant outside
um the chamber
um I believe this came
um
I think this was before the expulsion
votes but here's here's gen Z and the
protesters uh led by the Gen Z activist
here inside the capitol outside the the
Chamber of the
um of the house there listen to their
chant
might be precious
[Applause]
[__] you passes
[__] precious I couldn't say it much
better myself [__] you fascist it's
beautiful and I'm so happy to hear the f
word ringing through the halls of the
Tennessee Capitol there's nothing that
pleases me more a friend of mine wrote a
song about the Tennessee three we
listened last week uh to his uh to one
of his songs but I want to play this
song about the Tennessee three now that
last song we listened to was a funny
song this one's more of a serious song
Here is Tennessee Brando his his new
song called Stand with the Tennessee
three let's listen
all right folks I know I've been writing
a lot of funny songs lately but for this
one I had to get serious
they said right out loud we ain't gonna
fix it you better get used to the blood
we took to the streets to raise up our
horses too long enough is enough
the fascist move quickly the silence the
noise the strike so no one could see we
can't let them fall we gotta walk tall
stand with the Tennessee three
[Music]
you wanna talk save the children well
here's an idea keep them safe in their
schools no military weapons out on the
street in the hand of just any old food
if you want to see our babies prosper
and grow up in this land we call free
we get off back down stay strong on this
ground stand with the Tennessee threes
[Music]
no time for culture wars our children
are dying and we're tired of trying the
reason with lobbying [__]
the blood on your hands will only be
remembered
generations to see
they'll remember a time we didn't turn a
blind eye and we stood with the
Tennessee three
no this time we can't turn a blind eye
we gotta stand with the Tennessee threes
[Music]
there you go folks stand with the
Tennessee three not just this weekend
but from now until the end of time stand
with them spread Tennessee Brando's song
around and spread those clips around of
the great representative Justin Jordan
and the great representative Justin
Pearson and also representative Gloria
Johnson this weekend and on and on and
we we must fight because they fight for
us even though they fight in the house
of the Tennessee it is a fight worth
fighting for democracy
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty and we will
use our rights and our freedom freedom
as the Liberty vehicle to get where we
want to go in this country with equity
and equality for all
for life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
that is the pro-democracy Coalition that
is liberalism that is the founding
strength
of our democracy
until Monday
same time same place
Surfs Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn head ass Beacon